We've finally made it.
After 48 episodes,
two robberies
and one man disguising
himself as a couch,
yes that happened,
Money Heist reached
its thrilling conclusion.
This is not just
the end of season five,̧
but of all Money Heist,
and what a series
to go out on.
The Professor got to boogie,
Berlin had the world's first
one-man bar fight,
and we enjoyed the funkiest
rendition of Bella Ciao yet.
Even with the cops
at the door,
there's no stopping
the grooviest robbers on TV.
Money Heist's final run
also delivered answers
we've been waiting for:
how to get the gold
out of the bank,
how to get the robbers
out of the bank
and just what was
the relevance
of all those
Berlin flashbacks.
With the series wrapped up
and our thieves
scattered to the wind,
it's time to take a look
at the final episodes
and break down
the masterstrokes
of The Professor's
greatest plan yet.
As if it needs to be said,
beware spoilers!
Let's start with
the first part of the plan.
How do you get 90 tonnes
of gold out of a bank?
Turns out it takes
a smelter,
an industrial oil pump,
some complicated maths
and one very virile
oil rig worker.
Seven kids
with seven different women.
From the moment
the gang crack
the flooded vault
in part three,
and started melting the gold
into tiny pellets,
it was obvious
they weren't going
to transport the gold
via traditional means.
They were very open
about the fact.
Lisbon explained it
to the court
before being rescued
using the Paris plan.
The plan is to steal
90 tonnes of gold
from the national reserve.
We're melting it.
And the Professor spilled
the tiny golden beans
to Sierra,
but she chose
not to believe him.
It'll come out
mushed up with the water.
You think I'm stupid, right?
The answer came
in episode six of part five,
where Berlin visited an
oil rig in the Barent's Sea
a whole five years before
the Bank of Spain heist.
Here, we learn two things.
One, that Berlin makes
for a hugely fun passenger
on long trips.
And two, that the pumps
used by the rig have
the power to shift liquids
at high pressure.
This thing sucks stuff
from the seabed
as if it were baby food.
By mixing pellets
with vault water,
the robbers fill the drain
pipes under the bank
with gold.
This process uses
a small pump
which doesn't have the force
needed to push that gold
through the 11 miles of pipe
from the bank
to the storm water tank,
which is where Benjamin and
the gang are waiting for it.
Enter the industrial pump,
with the raw power to flush
the remaining vault water
and the pipe gold all the
way to the storm water tank
Too little pressure
and the gold
won't get there.
Too much
and the pipes will explode.
The tricky part is manually
controlling pressure
and calculating the values.
Palermo cites
Darcy Weisbach
which is an equation
in fluid dynamics
used to find
the impact of friction
on liquids
moving through a pipe.
For once,
The Professor has met
his galaxy-brained match.
Am I crazy or am I
the only one who sees this?
The final twist in the plan?
Instead of pumping
the gold downhill,
where the police
are more likely to look,
Palermo chooses
to pump it upstream.
We'll get the gold up the
river like fucking salmons,
to the storm water tank.
So when the police turn up
at the wrong
storm water tank,
there's not
a single gold ball in sight.
Of course,
maths only gets you so far.
To Palermo,
the plan is a love letter
to his time with Berlin
and it's his faith in that
plan and that relationship
that pushes
the gang and the gold
to where they need to be.
Speaking of Berlin,
the drainpipe plan feels
like an echo
of his earlier robbery
at Frederiksborg castle…
where he stole Viking
treasure with his son,
then used the river outside
to safely transport their
swag to another location.
And speaking of Raphael,
now's a good time to address
a tiny problem
in The Professor's plan.
No sooner have they
extracted the gold by pipe
and smelted it
back into ingots,
the team is robbed
by another gang of thieves
posing as policemen.
Yes, the irony
of robbers being robbed
isn't lost on us.
Our gold's been stolen.
The culprit?
Berlin's son Raphael
and former wife, Tatiana.
-We did it!
To pick this twist apart,
let's rewind
back a few years.
In part three,
we're introduced to Berlin's
new bride, Tatiana,
during one of the show's
many flashbacks.
On the plus side,
it means we get another
Berlin musical number.
But The Professor is alarmed
that Berlin has shared
his plans
for the Bank of Spain heist
with an outsider.
By the way, she loves
the Bank of Spain heist.
She knows.
Staying in the past,
but jumping
forwards a few months,
Berlin introduces Tatiana
to his son, Raphael.
He needs them both
to rob the Danish castle.
But while the Copenhagen job
goes without a hitch,
it ignites a spark between
Raphael and Tatiana,
and nervous looks
in the boat
blossom
into a full-on affair.
We'd feel bad for Berlin
but it's only what he taught
his son to do.
If you really want
something in life...
you have to steal it
from whoever has it.
This results
in the most expensive
bar bill in history
for a heartbroken Berlin.
But in a way,
it also triggers the entire
Money Heist story.
Berlin's broken heart
and stint in jail
for smashing the bar
is what opens him up
to working
with his brother,
The Professor,
on the original
Royal Mint heist.
Before I die,
you and I are going to rob
the Royal Mint of Spain.
Yes,
Money Heist is basically
just a really messy breakup.
Eating a massive tub
of Haagen-Dazs
would have been much easier.
Back in the present,
we have fun
seeing The Professor lose
his cool for a minute.
She's a pianist.
And a thief!
But it's also neat seeing
the family resemblance
between his work
and Raphael's.
The idea of Raphael
observing the crime scene
from a bank of monitors
is a classic Professor move.
as is
the attention to detail
when he and Tatiana hide
the gold under the house.
The total commitment
to the disguise is the same
as The Professor dressing
as a homeless man
back in season one,
to, yes, stapling
himself and Sierra
inside the couch.
Of course, Sierra
does get the gold back.
After The Professor realises
Raphael and Tatiana
must be hiding the loot,
Sierra tracks it by looking
for recently purchased land
and confronts
the pair of lovebirds.
And reclaiming the ingots
is crucial to the plan.
It's the answer
to the other huge question
hanging over the heist:
how to get the robbers
out of the bank.
Because while you may be
able to squeeze gold pellets
through 11 miles of pipe,
Helsinki is
more of a challenge.
Without the gold,
we're done for.
Then we're done for.
The short answer is
they plan to hold the gold
hostage outside the bank
to secure the release of
the robbers inside the bank.
That might sound
like backwards thinking,
but you have to remember
the whole point
of robbing the Spanish
Reserve in the first place
was to use it as a
bargaining chip to free Rio.
The gold was never
the real target.
For his plan to work,
The Professor needs
to apply financial pressure
to the Spanish government.
It's not enough
to take the gold.
As Tamayo explains,
the government have
safety nets in place.
Bad news.
I've got the support
of the European Central Bank
to inject cash or buy debt.
To amplify
the financial crisis,
the robbers broadcast
their successful
gold heist online.
In fact, watch back
through the series,
and you'll often see
characters filming
on their mobile phones.
No, it wasn't just
inappropriate TikToks,
they were documenting
their heist.
To further destabilise
the financial market,
The Professor plants
fake clues
to draw the police and army
to search
for the gold in the ocean.
Filling the storm water tank
with charred remains
of fake documents
reminds us of The Professor
planting fake leads
in his hideout
during the Royal Mint heist.
He loves a wild goose chase.
The plan is named
after Tom Thumb,
or as he's known in Spain,
Pulgarcito.
The original
Tom Thumb story's
where a tiny,
thumb-sized man
goes on wild adventures,
where he was passed
from bird to fish.
which could relate
to the long journey
Marseille leads Angel on
in pursuit of the gold.
But the Tom Thumb story's
also seen as a tale
about how a tiny hero
can take on
massive challenges.
Which does link nicely
to a handful of robbers
bringing down
a financial market.
With the stock market
plummeting,
The Professor can negotiate
with Tamayo
and offers to return it
in exchange
for their freedom.
This is why
the whole plan hinges
on retrieving the gold
from Raphael and Tatiana.
No bargaining chip,
no escape.
Which leads us
to the final twist.
The gold is returned,
despite currently being
buried under a house
and trapped in a standoff
between Sierra and Tatiana.
Yeah, it confused us too.
But this is the brilliance
of The Professor's plan.
He returns brass
coated in gold,
an idea he had
after noticing how his
food tins resembled ingots.
It's also an idea
with a proven
Money Heist track record.
Berlin's Copenhagen job
swapped Viking treasure
for brass fakes.
The twist hinges
on the concept
that the gold in the reserve
is more of an idea
than a valuable thing.
Countries don't spend it,
it just sits there,
underpinning the economy.
Throughout the series,
people are remarking
how no one can truly own
the gold.
After all, it just fell from
space millions of years ago.
And as Palermo notes
of historic gold…
This gold
was already stolen once.
It can't be stolen twice.
Finally, there's Lisbon
dropping a neat literary
reference to Tamayo.
Lazarillo de Tormes
wasn't written
by the English.
Was it?
Lazarillo de Tormes
is a novella
from the Spanish Golden Age
and follows
a young boy mastering
the art of thievery.
It was so influential,
it invented an entire genre,
the picaresque novel,
taken from the word picaro
meaning "rogue".
She's almost making the case
that ingenious deception
and improvisation,
the skills
that define The Professor,
are a key part of the
Spanish national character.
And so it is
they convince Tamayo
to work with them.
While the robbers fake
their deaths
to let him walk
away from the siege
with a bit of pride,
he also has to accept
the fake gold
in the name
of stabilising the markets.
And because the robbers
reclaimed the real gold
from Raphael and Tatiana,
they can use it
as a safety net.
They just need to expose its
existence outside the bank
to ruin the economy again.
And it's this that finally
secures their future.
It's one hell of a plan.
And so we reach the end
of the Bank of Spain heist.
It was not without
a few tears along the way,
rest in peace
Nairobi and Tokyo,
but it's also not the
bloodbath some expected.
There was
a popular fan theory
that more characters
would die.
Some people felt
the two teams of footballers
in part four
represented
who would live or die.
And others felt Nairobi's
heavenly flashback
pointed towards The
Professor's eventual death.
But it was not to be.
The biggest question
we still have
is why they never blocked up
those air vents.
Between Gandia, Stockholm
and Arantxe Arteche,
there was always someone
in the walls
during parts four and five.
Air vents, you are
the real MVP of Money Heist.
And that brings us to the
end of our Ending Explained.
Why not watch
our earlier theories videos
to see how they stacked up?
Well, after you've done
an entire Money Heist
series re-watch, of course.
For more videos like this,
subscribe
to Netflix: Still Watching
and we'll see you soon.